đường sức tử hướng để trải sáng trải, sẵn xong với mặt phản của phương dời.
Tỡ có nghe là tử thông phản không.
Bây giờ, đường thông là gì?
Đó miếng, đường thông là tử dường,
thông qua, xin qua, mặt phương dời.
Lột, đường sức tử, thông qua, xin qua, mặt phản phương dời,
thì đó qua là tử thông.
Nhưng mà ở đây, nghe là tử dường này xong xong với mặt phản của dời,
nó có xin qua, mặt phản của dời thông,
cho nên tử thông mà không.
Đấy là một cách giải trải thiết kết theo như thế.
Cách giải thiết được hai.
Cách giải thiết được đầm như thế.
Mặt phản của dời, của mặt phản của dời,
thì dây đầm ngàn phép tử phản của đầm như thế.
Dưa bà em thấy, mặt phản của dời,
đầm như thế, đầm như thế, đầm như thế.
Bởi vì của nghe là nấu anh phán lúc này thắng chiếm được.
Mặt thông công được đánh phuy bản của dân xin nhanh quốc.
W网 phá.
Bộ chiếm như thế, ngàn phân như thế,
của mặt phản của dây thông của không.
Cái đường sức tử,
nó xanh trằng với mặt, đầy.
Chào nி, mẹn, nó phản của bản của mặt phương đứt.
Bây giờ em có thể phá này có khó khó khó.